[Music]
hey everybody happy sunday happy boxing
day yeah for people in the uk and can't
don't they celebrate boxing day in
canada too oh i don't know
i might be high i'm not right i'm not
sure
we had problems starting the stream if
uh if you guys have any problems just go
ahead and drop a comment in the comment
section i'm trying to watch it now on my
what you call it and it's still it's way
behind well my shit's green but it's
great it's just i mean it started i
started losing the connection like
immediately like it started going into
the red
right like you know what i mean so it's
running green now so i mean we'll see we
had to restart the router jesus christ
i just want to drop kick the entire
internet whenever this happens it's so
frustrating it was a router issue must
have been it was because look it's
running smooth now fourth draw downs
give me a little boxing glove yeah
okay so we're uh talking about a movie
that uh i saw when i was a kid scared
the [ __ ] out of me 1980s called death
ship
yeah
it's weird because this is on amazon
prime on the free to me section
and i kept seeing it in there but for
whatever reason i didn't watch it
because i think i confused it with the
movie ghost ship from like 2002
or something like that is that the one
where everybody gets cut in half in the
first scene like with the wire and i so
i kept thinking it was that one so i was
like oh i've seen that one a couple
times but then when i was looking at the
description of this one i was like hey i
don't think i have seen this one and
tom's like yeah this is pretty much he
said it was the one that you saw as a
kid yeah this one is kind of like
i had it when as a kid i had it up there
with like the evil
and shock waves if you guys remember
shockwave shockwave is about the damn
nazi submariners a damn submarine we
should do shockwaves at some point so
i'm pretty sure it's on to be i think i
saw it on there the other day yeah
when that one they had so the nazis had
figured out how to make zombies and they
had a damn crew an undead crew of
zombies for their damn submarine had
peter cushing in it he was their captain
but he was alive
but the damn
ship was [ __ ] wrecked outside of
desert island he was hiding on there's a
good flick i remember to being good i
need to see it again maybe maybe we can
watch it tonight i'm pretty sure it's
free okay
and uh but what this one is about is it
it
and this one also came out around the
same time that i was watching the evil
which is a good haunted house movie this
was about a haunted
cargo ship that was working it was a
german cargo ship that was haunted with
a bunch of ghosts on it
and uh
you know
the reason why it's haunted is because
bad [ __ ] was happening on this ship it
was just usually why things are haunted
yes
[Laughter]
i guess some part of german intelligence
you know i don't know if it was ss or
gestapo or something
uh they were um using the ship as a uh
interrogation site and it was a remote
interrogation site that just went in a
circle it circled the atlantic again
yeah it never would go to land
and they didn't really explain much of
why it was haunted it just was and the
captain of the ships his ghost is still
on it and all the down bodies are still
on it and everything it's it's it's good
it's been out there for 30 years
when when these people find it
it's pretty cool fourth drawdown says
death ship was a problem for me because
i intrinsically trust george kennedy
yeah he usually plays a good guy not in
this one
even before he gets i mean this is an
old movie we can spoil it right this is
1980. um even though he does get
possessed
and starts doing nazi [ __ ] like on the
boat even before that before he gets
possessed when they're on the cruise
ship um he's still kind of a douche you
know what i mean well he was being
retired for being a dick
they said he was a good captain but he
couldn't deal with customers yeah he
wasn't a people person let's put it that
way i kept calling him mr grumpy pants
like throughout the whole because he was
just so [ __ ] cranky he was just like
old man yells at cloud type of dude yeah
he starts off as a captain on a um on a
luxury liner
and he doesn't want to hear people's
[ __ ] you know i mean people talking
about their dead husband he's like yeah
okay right he's just gonna whatever [ __ ]
off [ __ ] off yeah
[Laughter]
so
he's losing his career for being a dick
although he's old too i mean he's like
retirement age yeah he's a retired
retirement age anyway he's pretty pretty
uh
he's what he has 30 something years
experience yeah i think he says
well why they were out there at sea they
get rammed by a [ __ ] ship and they
kind of create creativity they kind of
use creative
ways to not show you this actual ramp
well i don't know if it was creative or
not it was basically just like oh my god
a ship comes in and there's like a hole
in the side of the boat and they show
water coming in and then the next scene
there's just like a raft they're just
like seven people on a raft right and
i'd be like oh i guess it's sick yeah i
said i guess they could afford to show
seven people on a raft they're just kind
of like random people that would that
they kind of introduced you to before
the crack the thing happened and then
floating out in the water they find the
captain he's about half dead they put
him in the raft
and then later on this ship comes up and
it's this big old black
scarred up looking it looks really cool
it is a real ship i don't know where
they got this ship jenny might have
researched it i didn't see yeah they
didn't really say i mean it is a real
ship real cargo shipments black
and they painted it black and it's uh
black and rusty and been out there for
[ __ ] ever and um
the
the the stairs to get up in it i don't
know what you call that i'm i'm i don't
you know i i'm a [ __ ] soldier i'm not
like a you know looking semen you know
but uh i said seaman yeah well they're
not sailors they'll [ __ ] slap you for
saying that i know they're not sailors
apparently according to wikipedia it's
called the boarding ladder boarding
ladder yeah i don't know if that's
correct boring ladder was down and they
get up in it
and uh
you know there's windows opening like
there's people looking down at them but
you don't see anything and then they
uh
like
it didn't want to let the captain in at
first did it
yeah it like not actually all of the
officers because there's three like
george kennedy he plays the captain
ashland was his name right captain
ashland and then the guy the younger guy
that's replacing him who's played by
richard crenna now he's on there with
his wife and his wife and kids survived
so that whole family's there and then
there was another officer
i can't remember what his name was but
he was played by nick mancuso
and i think his character's name was
nick too now that i'm thinking about it
and the three of them were trying to get
like george kennedy's kind of uh tubby
butt like up the stairs and uh the ship
was like nope and like kind of dumped it
off like when everyone else was on board
so it was trying to like prevent him
from getting on board at first now one
of the guys that makes it
that survived the origin the original
[ __ ]
wreck of the ship and the guy who was in
the raft
uh he was the i think he was the leader
of the damn band that was on the ship
yeah he was like the mc
right and he's a jewish guy all right
and these [ __ ] ghosts they [ __ ]
single him out [ __ ] first day he goes
that's gonna happen damn nazi ghost not
gonna let this jewish guy on the [ __ ]
ship all right and uh i don't want to
spoil that one that's a pretty good
that's a he gets taken out like pretty
good pretty quickly yeah
the ship they're like nope nope we're
not having your kind here they kill his
ass
pretty dastardly the way the ghosts got
him too [ __ ] and uh because it took
time and and everybody else were seeing
it happening that was a good thing about
this this ghost movie this haunted ship
movie is that a lot of it happened in
broad daylight in front of a bunch of
people it's not like it was singled you
out it did sometimes
but it usually when it killed somebody
it was in front of everybody else and it
didn't matter if it was night or day
which i thought that was that made it
even eerier for me
even when as a kid i was like whoa this
thing will kill you in broad daylight in
front of it with everything there's not
really much you can do about it about it
right so i was all as a kid it
intimidated me right off the bat and
that's one of the first dudes to die in
this movie and they just get in on the
ship
so it's fast
and uh well you know not fast his death
was slow
um but they do some sailor [ __ ] to him
the ghosts do you don't see them they're
just invisible all right
and uh the dude that played him you'll
recognize the guy who played the jewish
dude he's the dude that played the uh
the the ducks or the dukes biographer in
um
[ __ ] um
what was the name of that clint eastwood
unforgiveness unforgiven yeah it was all
reuben oh yeah that was that's the guy's
name and he's much younger and he's real
fit in this and uh he gets [ __ ] up he
also was on a couple of episodes of like
star trek the next next generation he
played like a collector who he tried to
make data into a statue that was a good
episode he was um i looked up his imdb
page and he's in a [ __ ] ton of stuff he
was in a tons of like movies tv he's
also a playwright i think um maybe a
novelist he was in unforgiven yeah he
was in wall street he was in true
romance yeah nixon yeah uh he was in the
ballot of buster scruggs that that's
coen brothers right that was on netflix
netflix a year or two ago he was on that
um yeah so he's been in a [ __ ] ton of
stuff you'll recognize him he's been in
like everything so i'm going to go
directly it's a very early role for him
if
if if you're jewish you're going to like
this movie because it's [ __ ] a horror
movie about damn nazi ghosts
i like that they didn't see i like that
you don't see them you know what i mean
i mean maybe that was budgetary
constraints because this doesn't really
seem like it was all that high budget
and when i looked it up it's actually
it's a canadian
uk co-production yeah and a lot of it
was filmed in the in um canada and and
it's strangely a big part of it filled
in alabama yeah and out in the gulf of
mexico off the coast of alabama but i
looked it up and on wikipedia it said it
only got a limited
theatrical release it was only released
in 250 theaters and only in three states
florida wisconsin yeah and texas this
would play well in florida it has a it
has kind of a meta kind of a a floridian
feel to it because it's out in the gulf
of mexico yeah they shot some of them in
the glass and you can it kind of has
that feel to it it's like something out
of them down below triangle or something
you know you don't know where it's
happening yeah he's supposed to be in
the atlantic i think but that it doesn't
it doesn't look or feel like i think
well according to what because i didn't
really get i don't even know if they
said this but like at the first
beginning part when they were having
like the big costume party or whatever
um you know on the cruise ship before it
gets rammed
um i think it's supposed to be in the
caribbean like it's a cruise line that's
just going around the caribbean it feels
like characters yeah i think that's what
it was supposed to be so did shock waves
shock waves is real that was nazis
that's nazi sea zombies with uh you
gotta see that one that's another one
shock waves
[ __ ] like i said maybe we'll watch
that tonight and uh because i'm pretty
sure it's on toby submarine nazi
submarine zombies
but yeah but i like this i like the way
they went about because anything that's
like about ghost ships is creepy yeah um
so you the fact that you get you know
you're in a [ __ ]
life raft and then you get actually
wasn't even a life raft i don't think i
think it was just like a piece of the
boat that it sunk or something yeah but
uh i think as hard no it wasn't yeah it
wasn't no it wasn't was it dinghy i
guess it wasn't
yeah i couldn't tell it was just like i
couldn't tell if it was a piece of
wreckage it didn't look like a standard
lifeboat is what i'm saying so i wasn't
really sure if it was just like the
strengths of this movie is that it's on
location in this [ __ ] ship and this
ship is ratty as [ __ ] in it through most
of it
other places it's a dab
looks normal you know what i mean but
it's all [ __ ] unused
and uh and and you find secret
compartments in there that are down
nazi shrines to the funds einstein
einstein's group and [ __ ]
nazi shirt they walk into this one room
i don't remember if it was like the
captain's quarters or whatever and he
walked in and i said gosh do you think
he maybe likes nazi [ __ ]
the whole thing is [ __ ] red i mean
the
walls the ceiling everything and there's
just like [ __ ] nazi flags and like a
big painting of adolf hitler i'm like
yeah and i was like yeah it might be a
little bit over the top yeah like a
little over the top
and what was funny is that the painting
of hitler is in its own special room
after the red room all right so whoa you
open it up and there he is
and then in the red room there's nothing
but like kriegsmarine [ __ ] uh flags
and [ __ ] um kriegsmarine [ __ ]
propaganda posters and it's all in
[ __ ] nice
uh [ __ ] frames and the lighting looks
really good and it is eerie when they go
in there
and then eventually through all this
[ __ ] people are dying in weird [ __ ]
ghostly ways
oh a woman dies because she eats some
damn candy
and i think this never explains that's
another thing that's great about this
movie is it never explains anything
i think she ate the candy and i think
the candy were suicide pills
even though it looked like those like
kind of round peppermints by peppermints
but i but they were in the captain's
quarters i believe weren't they in a big
jar i think it was the captain's
quarters well i don't i thought it might
have been like the crew quarters because
there was more than one bed okay i think
there was more than one bunk in there
well it was
that might have secretly been
the suicide pills although you think
they'd put like a label on that like hey
don't eat these unless you want to die
spycraft would have it disguised as
something else so you don't so
they just have to tell all the new crew
members when they come on board please
don't eat them
orders this is poison
because you don't want your captors to
know it's poison because you want to you
want to ask for it you know what i mean
give us that candy you know just [ __ ]
like that you know they hide that [ __ ] a
lot of times
um spycraft has is all into them [ __ ]
secret james bond [ __ ] but she died from
something after eating that yeah she
kind of like turned she started to like
decompose or something but then george
kennedy strangled her though
well he was possessed well i know that
but yeah
yeah in case we didn't mention that he
actually gets possessed by and he
strangled her because he thought he
thought that she was one of the crewmen
remember to be shown what he saw say he
was killing his own crew
because as it turns out the crew all
killed themselves
i don't think so though because
he killed the wikipedia page said that
all those people you know when they go
in the freezer and there's all these
people hanging yeah um wikipedia page
said those were raf and russian oh okay
okay uh that they so the actual crew
members i guess we're just haunting
okay but you did so you didn't see them
because like i said you don't see the
ghosts so maybe they that's who they
were interrogating they were
interrogating the rf because i i knew
that those were pilots all right they
were in pilots uniforms but i didn't
really know through a german pilot in
the british pilots uniforms
yeah that makes sense now
but uh
you don't know what happened to the crew
i guess the crew went overboard
well i would assuming i was assuming
that the crew were still there they were
just ghosts now yeah but what happened
to their mortal bodies
oh i don't know well but they had to
have died somehow
were those the bodies that that dude
fell in at the end or were those their
victim's bodies or maybe it was a combo
yeah maybe that was just like they right
or like you said they might have just
threw him overboard because when that
woman dies
george kennedy like you know wraps her
up
they were killing jewish people in there
but i guess not it didn't make sense
they were killing the raf guys they were
they were killing allied people there
because why would they
because the big plot hole is like why
the hell do you need that when you have
concentration camps
well you answered it that was it's a
mobile they weren't they weren't doing
that to jewish to to jewish people in
there it was it was raf people they were
though because
remember they went into that one place
and there was like all those corpses in
there yeah and then there were gold
teeth and like jewelry and stuff well
they might have just so they were
interrogating yeah but i don't think
those were jews i just think they were
just allied people
british and russian people well maybe
they had gold teeth too well no but i'm
saying that maybe they had like a
different [ __ ] they're like well if
you're not jewish but you're raf or
whatever will just hang you in the
freezer but if you are jewish
you know then well
interrogations though right and you see
they didn't even bother interrogating
jewish people we're thinking about this
probably more than the people that did
i think it was just not i think they
were interrogating them allied troops
there
for infamous battle information they
didn't interrogate jewish people they
just killed them because they didn't
know anything they were civilians
you know what i mean but yeah so uh yeah
zach was saying um that he said the only
part of this movie that [ __ ] him up
was the woman in the blood shower but
other than that he thought it was kind
of cheesy yeah it is kind of but it's
still fun though yeah it's a fun movie
man this is [ __ ] for 1980 i think it
was 1980 this came out right this was a
good movie for 1980. it was on location
in that ship
that's that right there is [ __ ]
so you see that nowadays honestly the uh
yeah the whole atmosphere and the sort
of verisimilitude of like being on the
ship and everything really gives this a
lot of atmosphere that it might not have
had otherwise a set would not have
[ __ ] done it it was because it was
actually on that ship
same thing with like the
the old movie the island that had
michael caine in it they actually were
on a damn
coast guard ship and they doing that and
a set can never match the real thing and
they really were on those islands and
they really were in those little boats
and diggies and [ __ ] doing stuff
you know just nowadays i'm trying to do
a lot of that [ __ ] with cgi and sets and
stuff
to save money but uh
no back then they actually just we're
gonna rent it and then you know call the
coast guard the coast guard will help us
out and we'll film this movie because
that really what that really was the
coast guard it thanks them in the end of
the movie the the island
they decided to to make a movie
with with michael caine in it
well yeah yeah we did we did a review of
that yeah um no what was i gonna say oh
okay so
the one kid there was a kid that was in
this movie the little boy that pees all
the time yeah um it was dumb i think his
name was ben yeah well they just had to
have that so he would go off on his own
sometimes because it's like i was like
that kid's got some bladder problems you
need to go to the doctor but um
it was bugging me the whole [ __ ]
movie because i'm looking at this kid
and i'm like that kid is so [ __ ]
familiar where the hell have i seen him
before
and for a time i thought you know what
that looks like the kid that was in pod
people on mst
and so i was like really trying to find
out like who the [ __ ] that was
but
it's not the same kid like that kid that
was in pod people was actually a french
kid
um this kid i can't remember what the
actor's name was uh [ __ ] i can't
remember what his name was but i looked
him up his imdb page and he's been in
like some movies and stuff but he wasn't
in anything that i had seen
so i can't figure out like why he looks
so familiar to me unless he just looks
so much like the kid from pod people
that i'm just
that that's just you know what i mean
that i'm just thinking he's the kid from
pod people even though it's not because
that's a totally different kid
but
you know you know i was looking up like
all the actors and directors and stuff
for this
because i was like curious and uh nick
mancuso being in this i knew he would he
had been on like stingray from like tv
and stuff he's been like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
ton of stuff too but something that i
discovered about nick mancuso that i
didn't know and i don't know if you guys
know this either was that he was billy's
voice on the phone from the original
black christmas and that kind of like
blew my mind that dude that was i was
like oh my god i didn't know that he was
in under siege as well i think
um the director of this this is a fun
little fact the director of this was a
canadian dude named alvin rakoff rakoff
not really sure
and um he mostly did tv
uh starting out in the late 50s and i
think he worked until like the mid 90s
late 90s
and he did a lot of like um like
teleplays like televised plays
particularly on british tv and he won a
bunch of uh awards for that but the fun
fact that i discovered was that he was
the guy the director that gave sean
connery his first leading role
in the 1957 like teleplay requiem for a
heavyweight which was written by rod
of all people isn't that nate i thought
that was neat but yeah so
i don't yeah this is it's it's a cheesy
movie it's not it's got boobies in it
like especially like there's the whole
woman that's in the shower and it's
inexplicably starts bleeding on her and
she flips out she's british too so she
can show her boobs
[Laughter]
i guess wait is that actress british the
younger one she was the older one was
the older woman was uh sally and howe's
that was she was from she was the one in
the shoes
no no no no no that was a different
woman there was two different women yeah
i think the slightly older woman yeah
with the british accent was the one
that's character was married to richard
krenna's character and then the younger
one was the one that was kind of like
the on-again off-again girlfriend of the
younger officer played by nick mate
dave they were i think they were trying
to pass her off as american but to me it
was she sounded british i couldn't
really tell she didn't really talk all
that much
but she was the one that was in but the
slightly older woman was uh sally anne
house who i think was mostly a stage
actress but she was in chitty chitty
background i think the younger one was
supposed to be american but i kind of
detected a british accent you guys can
check you know you guys are online yeah
i can't remember i think she was british
but yeah so yeah you do get to see uh a
naked woman covered with blood in a
shower so that's neat yeah zach said
that's what freaked him out the most
naked woman that freaked his
ew
yeah there it's not a real um it's not
graphic it's not a real gory movie uh at
all like most of the people get killed
and sort of i don't want to say prosaic
ways necessarily but i did however like
how george kennedy's character died at
the end even though they don't
they don't show it like completely but i
think they filmed it in a way that
was like good because it implied like a
lot grosser than they actually showed
now the uh
it does have some good effects for dead
bodies it shows a lot of dead bodies
yeah i do like all the corpse effects
and they look good they look they look
real good
um there's some german dialogue in it
the ghost of the old german captain is
[ __ ] talking to the old captain i
don't know if
sandra can tell us if that's real german
or if that's somebody just hired it
apparently is because on the blu-ray
yeah um they have a german speaker doing
it uh who tells you like what what what
all what the guy i don't know what he
was saying something about
it was his ship at the beginning i think
that's all i know at the end at the very
end like when you know the people escape
from the boat and whatever uh and then
the german or the ghost ship sees
another ship and was like oh we're gonna
go ram that one because the ghosts need
blood i guess yeah so they have to like
kill people yeah um so the german that
they're saying in that one they're
saying something like enemy in sight or
something like that so i know that so it
is actual german okay um they're not
just making it up i was like millions
and millions of people in the world
speak german it'd be really dumb to just
kind of let them go on there and just
like pretend no one have it's like fake
caster knowing how these movies are made
it's really not hard to find somebody
that could name it this is a canadian
movie so they're going to put a german
in there
if this was a movie from california
they'd have [ __ ] canon reeves [ __ ]
trying to just hear man read that out in
german you know i mean his [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] trying to rip out the german be
[ __ ] atrocious yeah it sounds good
enough roll with it
whatever who's being german anyway
nobody yeah nobody will know what you're
saying exactly
[Laughter]
but yeah apparently it is actual german
yeah i don't know what it all says but i
have seen i have seen that somebody
translated it i think it's a special
feature like on the dvd or the blu-ray
or whatever yeah this kind of to me this
feels like a movie that i didn't see
this back in the day i'm pretty sure i
saw it they were playing it on hbo
there because it didn't look it didn't
look very good on television it looked a
lot better on an hd tv now with it with
in hd like it was intended to be seen on
a big screen it looks good
the old television format
was still scary but it doesn't look
anywhere near as good it looks good i
liked it but hey it's i like retro
movies from this era i grew up with them
yeah they're they're imperfect there is
cheese in them
but it's kind of like a walk past down
memory lane and just the way the movies
used to be and i i still find them
entertaining i put this up there with
like
shock waves which shock waves might have
been a little shittier actually but i
still liked it i know i've seen shock
waves but it's been a long time since
i've seen shockwaves might have been a
little shitty so now i'm kind of curious
to like watch it again we'll have to
watch it later
you [ __ ] had that british actor in it
you know that's he you know what's his
name [ __ ] the dude from star wars it
had him in it so he he made that movie
what's that guy's name
voice the center of the earth you know
you like a skinny dude back teeth
back to you guys peter cushing peter
cushion
cushing's in shock waves just say he he
carries that whole movie
well i mean peter cushing is a [ __ ]
class actor right him and christopher
lee they're they just elevate everything
what in the hell she brought that in
here
she can transport that
yeah how did you bring that in here
how'd you get that in here polka you
must have had it in your teeth i guess
she picked up a snowman for
care to snow for christmas i bought her
little it's called snacky the snowman
and it's like temptations it's like this
little snow little round snowman and you
put treats in it and when you knock it
over
treats come out of its butt and it was
or it's not it's butt i guess it's side
and i we had it way over there in the
living room she carried that in and she
just brought it in here and it's because
it's empty oh she's like refill this
mama we'll put some more treats in it
do you like this is [ __ ] right here
yeah it's [ __ ] here man
there was a lot of treats in there
i put i filled it all the way up like i
filled it up so much that it was they
were like leaking out she knows that the
treats go in there i can't believe she
carried that all the way in here yeah
and then she brings it in here for us to
refill yeah refill this [ __ ] oh my god
that's hilarious funny man you're the
weirdest guy she's a smart cat
she understands the game
when we uh we she wouldn't come
downstairs to unwrap her present
so we had to bring it because i kept
going come down here pookie i have a
present for you and she's just like no
i'm not doing that so we had to bring it
upstairs
and then so i gave her that and then
when we opened it like tom was like
ripping the paper and she was like
flipping out she was just like no
and she ran away i thought someone's
gonna come on get her i think so i was
like when is that gonna i don't know why
she's so jumpy
she's a cat you're constantly living on
the edge of panic
i guess so it's like no just like no
nobody's ever look at her she's like
staring at tom going like hurry up here
you go
there's your little snowman in there now
yeah there's treats in there
she's like thank you
yeah she knows what it means she's like
yeah she smelled it she goes there it is
oh okay good
that's just like i wonder we just heard
some clatter over there on the floor and
i was like holy crap she brought that
all the way in here she's pushing it
over that's crazy so we got anything
else to say about this probably not uh i
guess this is the first i hope everybody
had a good christmas i forgot i forgot
to say
we still have like 40 bajillion tons of
food left i haven't even eaten anything
today actually now that i think about it
it gets them to eat i know we got a good
guess yeah so watch this turkey and
potatoes and all kinds of stuff you guys
should watch this one and then when you
get done with this one you can watch
shockwaves i was going to say this one
is almost kind of like it's like a cool
like supernatural horror plus nazis plus
it almost has a little bit of a disaster
movie value to it too especially in the
beginning yeah it's because
because the cruise ship gets rammed yeah
and then but like i said i kind of
laughed because
obviously you could tell if they didn't
have the budget to show like the cruise
ship sinking yeah so it's just
it just kind of like was like oh there's
this big party
which i don't know if it was supposed to
be new years or halloween everybody had
costumes on and um and then basically
they had one shot of you know what you
assume is like the front of the other
ship like coming into
you know smashing into the hall and
there's like all this water and then it
just like cuts immediately to
you know people survivors like there's
no so there's there was no footage of
like sinking or anything like that but i
was just kind of like okay well that
that was uh economical wasn't it
but that yeah that kind of kind of made
me laugh so it does have like some
cheesy elements to it and like some
stuff that made me laugh but it's not
really that cheesy i mean other than the
little boy peeing all the time um you
know the pod people kid he wasn't the
pod people kid
and
the funny thing where they went way over
the top with like the nazi memorabilia
in that one room that's like i don't
know why that made me laugh so hard it
was a whole shrine just like when we put
it there i'm like oh you think he likes
nazi [ __ ] yeah
it was like a shrine i was like damn
let's dial it back a couple notches
i was like look the the ceiling was red
too not just the walls it'd have bread
walls and a red ceiling i thought that
was like a nice touch but yeah
so um yeah this was this was super fun
it's actually if you have amazon prime
you can watch it for free i like i said
i didn't watch it for a long time
because zach was saying i still prefer
uh ghost ship from 2002. and for a long
time i didn't watch this because i
thought this was ghost ship and i'd
already seen that like a couple times
but then i was like oh wait no this is
like a completely different movie and i
had never seen this one
even though this totally looks like
something that i would have watched back
in the day but i guess i didn't
but uh yeah so
all right i guess it's uh sunday like i
said hopefully you guys had a really
good christmas we had a really nice
little good christmas eating a lot of
food and
watching what did we watch last night
other than this
oh we then i watched like the rift
tracks of
jack frost right so that was
we were going to watch christmas
chronicles 2 but we never got around to
it too late now we got to wait till next
year
oh well at least we watched the first
one so we did that all right so uh
anyway
have a good day after christmas have a
good rest of your weekend and we will
see you guys again tomorrow talking
about another movie thanks for dropping
by